as the Trump administration deals with
the corona virus pandemic the White
House is also stepping up its efforts to
remove venezuela's President Nicolas
Maduro from office just days after the
US Justice Department indicted Maduro
for alleged narco-terrorism Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo announced a plan for a
transition government in Venezuela
broadly speaking it would put the
elected members of the National Assembly
Assembly representing both sides would
create a an acceptable Council of state
to serve as the transitional government
until presidential and National Assembly
elections could be held we hope within
six to 12 months in exchange the US
would lift harsh economic and diplomatic
sanctions even on the sale of oil
Venezuela's lifeline the plan calls for
both Maduro and the opposition leader
Hwang who I though was recognized by
Washington as the legitimate president
to step aside why though is already on
board
the most amazes today we have
international support for a proposal
that we made months ago for an orderly
transition of power that gives
guarantees and space to all those who
stand by our Constitution Maduro wasted
no time responding in a communique the
government says that quote neither
extortion nor false Accords will
distract president Maduro and the armed
forces from their mission to protect the
Venezuelan people but Washington is
betting that the growing pandemic on top
of plummeting oil prices and US economic
sanctions will make this offer more
palatable for those who could force
medoras hand
indeed the initiative sounds remarkably
familiar it's apparently the brainchild
of Under Secretary of State for Western
Hemisphere affairs Mike Kozak and
Special Representative for Venezuela
Elliott Abrams the same two men who in
1989 presented a very similar exit
strategy to form a Panamanian strong man
general Manuel Antonio Noriega Noriega
refused and six months later he was
ousted by a US military invasion he's
human the lmperial emo if the
imperialists and the Colombian oligarchy
dare to touch a hair on our heads
prepare for the Bolivarian fury the fury
of a people who will lash out at all of
you US State Department sources have
been quoted as saying the u.s. military
intervention is not in the cards but
that a surgical strike could achieve the
same goal the ball is now in Mugu rose
court to see if he will call
Washington's Bluff
you see inhuman al Jazeera Santiago